أجنبي
أشعر بالحرية حقًا عندما أكون أمام عيني،
أحب حقًا الشعور
بالرياح والشعور كلما
قمت بالقفز والدوران، الأمر يشبه
الطيران تقريبًا،
هذه هي حلبة التزلج على الجليد الوحيدة هنا في
أبيلابي، هذه الحلبة هي ملكي  المنزل الثاني
[موسيقى] مرحبًا،
أنا زهراء لاري وهذا هو
المكان المضيف لمدينة أبو لافي صهيون الرياضية
للمسابقات الدولية مع
ملعب كرة قدم مصنف من قبل الاتحاد الدولي لكرة القدم وملعب مركزي
لبطولات اتحاد لاعبات التنس المحترفات السنوية التي
تقع بين هذه المدرجات
حلبة أبو ظبي للتزلج على الجليد  حيث بدأت زارا مسيرتها
المهنية بفوزها بألقاب لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
وكسرت الحدود لتصبح
أول متزلجة على الجليد تتنافس مرتدية
الحجاب
في قلب التزلج، وهذا هو السبب وراء
تزايد الاهتمام بجميع الرياضات الشتوية أم أن لديك الهوكي، فهم
ينمون كثيرًا  على مر
السنين، أصبح التزلج على الجليد أكثر شعبية
هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
فهي دولة صحراوية، لذا فإن الجو حار جدًا،
لذا يميل الناس إلى المجيء للتزلج. ربما تكون
البطلة الوطنية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة خمس مرات قد
تقاعدت من المنافسة
الاحترافية، لكن زارا لم
تعتزل حذائها.  ومع ذلك، سأركز على
الجيل القادم من الأطفال الذين لدينا
هنا، فأنا أحب حقًا رؤية تقدمهم
سواء كانوا يتعلمون
قفزة جديدة، وفي النهاية بعد
أشهر من المحاولة تمكنوا من تحقيق تلك القفزة
ورؤية الابتسامة فقط  وجههم ولد
ونشأ في أبو ظبي زارا هي أيضًا
الرئيس التنفيذي لنادي الإمارات للتزلج
وتنظم مسابقات
تجذب مئات المتزلجين من الشرق الأوسط
وأوروبا يا
شباب أحتاج إلى هذه الزعنفة لتكون أسرع بكثير
الجميع يحب القدوم إلى المنافسة
عندما نستضيفه هنا في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة لأنهم يأتون إلى هنا يقومون
بالمنافسة ويمكنهم الاسترخاء
بعد ذلك يمكنهم
الجمع بين المنافسة وأيضًا
الإجازة بعد ذلك ويمكنهم الذهاب ورؤية
عالم فيراري يمكنهم الذهاب إلى الشاطئ
ولكن  يوجد مكان واحد في ألكانا،
أحدث مشاريع تطوير الواجهة المائية في أبو ظبي،
بالقرب من مسجد شيك سايد حيث تذهب زارا
للاسترخاء على
إيقاع وحركة الحياة البحرية،
الهدوء والصمت
بالنسبة لزارا، حوض السمك هو ملاذها،
أما حوض السمك المحيط، فإن أي شيء يتعلق
بالمياه يهدئني حقًا.
وأعتقد أن الأمر يبطئ الأمور قليلاً
وأستطيع التنفس
عندما أذهب إلى هناك، أشعر
بالهدوء حقًا،
يمكنني فقط استعادة تركيزي
وتصفية كل ما أملكه
والانتعاش ومواصلة يومي
[موسيقى]
مع المزيد  أكثر من 46000 كائن منتشر
في 10 مناطق، يعد حوض الأسماك الوطني هو
الأكبر في الشرق الأوسط حيث
يعرض الحياة البرية في مناخات مختلفة
هنا لدينا بعض طيور البفن والبط القطبي الشمالي،
هذا هو المحيط المتجمد وهذا
مكاني أكثر
[موسيقى]
أحب أحواض السمك أنا  لا أعرف شيئا
عن الماء فهو هادئ للغاية وكأن
حياتي محمومة للغاية ومشغولة للغاية
خاصة الآن بعد أن أصبحت أمًا أحاول تحقيق
التوازن في كل شيء [
موسيقى]
تلك مخيفة أنا مرعوب من
أسماك القرش ولكن ما زلت أحب المشاهدة  لهم
لأنني آمن، أنا بالخارج
فلا بأس
[موسيقى]
يضم حوض السمك فريقًا مكونًا من 80 شخصًا
بما في ذلك الغواصين وعلماء الأحياء البحرية
الذين يعتنون بجميع الحيوانات البرية
بما في ذلك مستشفى للحيوانات حيث يقومون
برعاية صغار السلاحف البحرية الموجودة على الشواطئ
المحيطة بأبو.  ظبي
[موسيقى]
البيئة وأعني شيئًا
لدينا وأعتقد أننا يجب أن
نعتني به حقًا، هذه هي
الطريقة المثالية لرؤية
[موسيقى]